I'm a big believer in living on 10 of
your income and before you get triggered
first you make more money the second
thing is that you spend basically as
little as humanly possible and to give
you context to this the first place that
I started renting when I was making
twenty thousand dollars a month in
income I was splitting a single bedroom
in a seven bedroom house so I had seven
roommates and one of them lived in the
exact bedroom with me so two dudes and I
had my mattress on the floor and it was
the only thing that I owed I believe in
that because one when you've lived on
nothing you know that it doesn't make
you any happier to have more you also
know that you were just as happy when
you had nothing so then you don't have
the same risk and fear as you grew up
which means you can take the risks that
are necessary to grow and third you have
to learn the discipline of delayed
gratification if you immediately spend
your check every month you'll never
learn the discipline of saying no now so
that I can have yes later